Euler continued to
investigate properties
of numbers, specifically the
distribution of prime numbers.
One important
function he defined
is called the phi function.
It measures the
breakability of a number.
So given a number, say
n, it outputs how many
integers are less than
or equal to n that do not
share any common factor with n.
For example, if we want
to find the phi of 8,
we look at all
values from 1 to 8,
then we count how many
integers 8 does not
share a factor
greater than 1 with.
Notice 6 is not counted
because it shares a factor of 2
while 1, 3, 5, and 7 are all
counted because they only
share a factor of 1.
Therefore phi of 8 equals 4.
What's interesting is that
calculating the phi function
is hard, except in one case.
Look at this graph.
It is a plot of values of phi
over integers from 1 to 1,000.
Now, notice any
predictable pattern?
The straight line of
points along the top
represent all the prime numbers.
Since prime numbers have no
factors greater than one,
the phi of any prime number,
p, is simply p minus 1.
To calculate phi of
7, a prime number,
we count all integers
except 7, since none of them
share a factor with 7.
Phi of 7 equals 6.
So if you're asked to find
phi of 21,377, a prime number,
you would only need to subtract
1 to get the solution, 21,376.
Phi of any prime
is easy to compute.
This leads to an interesting
result based on the fact
that the phi function
is also multiplicative.
That is, phi a times b
equals phi a times phi b.
If we know some number n is
the product of two primes, p1
and p2, then phi of
n is just the value
of phi for each prime
multiplied together,
or p1 minus 1 times p2 minus 1.